[Music]
after seeing how we think about ordinary
differential equations in Chapter one we
turn now to an example of a partial
differential equation the heat equation
to set things up imagine you have some
object like a piece of metal and you
know how the heat is distributed across
it at any one moment that is what's the
temperature of every individual point
along this plate the question is how
will this distribution change over time
as the heat flows from warmer spots to
cooler ones the image on the Left shows
the temperature of an example plate
using Color with the graph of that
temperature being shown on the right to
take a concrete one-dimensional example
let's say you have two different rods at
different temperatures where that
temperature is uniform along each one
you know that when you bring them into
contact the temperature will flow from
the hot one to the cool one tending to
make the whole thing equal over time but
how exactly what will the temperature
distribution be at each point in time as
is typical with differential equations
the idea is that it's easier to describe
how this setup changes from moment to
moment than it is to jump straight to a
description of the full evolution we
write this rule of change in the
language of derivatives though as you'll
see we'll need to expand our vocabulary
a bit beyond ordinary derivatives and
don't worry we'll learn how to read the
equation you're seeing now in just a
minute
variations of the heat equation show up
in many other parts of math and physics
like Brownian motion the black Scholes
equations from finance and all sorts of
diffusion so there are many dividends to
be had from a deep understanding of this
one set up in the last video we looked
at ways of building understanding while
acknowledging the truth that most
differential equations are simply too
difficult to actually solve and indeed
PDEs tend to be even harder than OD ease
largely because they involve modeling
infinitely many values changing in
concert but our main character for today
is an equation that we actually can
solve in fact if you've ever heard of
Fourier series you may be interested to
know that this is the physical problem
which baby-faced Fourier over here was
trying to solve when he stumbled across
the corner of math that is now so
replete with his name
we'll dig in to Fourier series much more
deeply in the next chapter but I would
like to give you at least a little hint
of the beautiful connection which is to
come this animation you're seeing right
now shows how lots of little rotating
vectors each rotating at some constant
integer frequency can trace out an
arbitrary shape to be clear what's
happening is that these vectors are
being added together tip to tail at each
moment and you might imagine that the
last one has some sort of pencil at its
tip tracing a path as it goes for
finitely many vectors this tracing
usually won't be a perfect replica of
the target shape which in this animation
is a lowercase F but the more circles
you include the closer it gets what
you're seeing now uses only 100 circles
and I think you'd agree that the
deviations from the real shape are
negligible what's mind-blowing is that
just by tweaking the initial size and
angle of each vector that gives you
enough control to approximate any curve
that you want at first this might seem
like an idle curiosity a neat art
project but little more in fact the math
that makes this possible is the same as
the math describing the physics of heat
flow but we're getting ahead of
ourselves
step one is simply to build up the heat
equation and for that let's start by
being clear about what the function
we're analyzing is exactly we have a rod
in one dimension and we're thinking of
it as sitting on an x axis so each point
of that rod is labeled with a unique
number X the temperature is some
function of that position T of X shown
here as a graph above it but really
since the value changes over time we
should think of this function as having
one more input T for time you could if
you wanted think of this input space as
really being two-dimensional
representing space and time together
with the temperature being graphed as a
surface above it each slice across time
showing you what that distribution looks
like at any given moment
or you could simply think of this graph
of temperature changing with time both
are equivalent this surface is not to be
confused with what I was showing earlier
the temperature graph of a 2-dimensional
body be mindful when you're studying
equations like these of whether time is
being represented with its own axis or
if it's being represented with literal
changes over time say in an animation
last chapter we looked at some systems
where just a handful of numbers changed
over time like the angle and angular
velocity of a pendulum describing that
change in the language of derivatives
but when we have an entire function
changing with time the mathematical
tools become slightly more intricate
because we're thinking of this
temperature function with multiple
dimensions to its input space in this
case one for space and one for time
there were multiple different rates of
change at play there's the derivative
with respect to X how rapidly the
temperature changes as you move along
the rod you might think of this as the
slope of our surface when you slice it
parallel to the x axis or given a tiny
step in the X direction and the tiny
change to temperature caused by it this
gives a ratio between the two but
there's also the rate at which a single
point on the rod changes with time what
you might think of as the slope of the
surface when you slice it in the other
direction parallel to the time axis each
one of these derivatives tells only part
of the story for how this temperature
function changes so we call them partial
derivatives to emphasize this point the
notation changes a little replacing the
letter D with a special curly D
sometimes called del personally I think
it's a little silly to change the
notation for this since it's essentially
the same operation I would rather see
notation that emphasizes that the Del T
terms up in the numerators refer to
different changes one is a small change
to temperature after a small change in
time the other is a small change to
temperature after a small step in space
to reiterate a point I made in the
calculus series I do think it's healthy
to initially read derivatives like this
as a literal ratio between a small
change to the functions output and the
small change to the input that caused it
just keep in mind that what this
notation is meant to encode is the limit
of that ratio for smaller and smaller
nudges to the input rather than a
specific value of the ratio for a
finitely small nudge this goes for
partial derivatives just as much as it
does for ordinary derivatives the heat
equation is written in terms of these
partial derivatives it tells us that the
way this function changes with respect
to time depends on how it changes with
respect to space
more specifically it's proportional to
the second partial derivative with
respect to X at a high level the
intuition is that at points where the
temperature distribution curves it tends
to change more quickly in the direction
of that curvature since a rule like this
is written using partial derivatives we
call it a partial differential equation
this has the funny result that to an
outsider the name sounds like a tamer
version of ordinary differential
equations when quite to the contrary
partial differential equations tend to
tell a much richer story than OD ease
and are much harder to solve in general
the general heat equation applies to
bodies in any number of dimensions which
would mean more inputs to our
temperature function but it'll be
easiest for us to stay focused on the
one-dimensional case of a rod as it is
graphing this in a way which gives time
its own axis already pushes our visuals
into the third dimension so I threw out
this equation but where does this come
from how could you think of something
like this yourself well for that let's
simplify things by describing a discrete
version of the setup where you have only
finitely many points X in a row this is
sort of like working in a pixelated
universe where instead of having a
continuum of temperatures we have a
finite set of separate values the
intuition here is simple for a
particular point if it's two neighbors
on either side are on average hotter
than it is it will heat up
if they're cooler on average it'll cool
down here specifically focus on these
three neighboring points X 1 X 2 and X 3
with corresponding temperatures T 1 T 2
and T 3 what we want to compare is the
average of T 1 and T 3 with the value of
T 2 when this difference is greater than
0 T 2 will tend to heat up and the
bigger the difference the faster it
heats up
likewise if it's negative T 2 will tend
to cool down at a rate proportional to
that difference more formally we write
that the derivative of T 2 with respect
to time is proportional to the
difference between this average value of
its neighbors and its own value alpha
here is simply a proportionality
constant to write this in a way which
will ultimately explain the second
derivative in the heat equation let me
rearrange this right-hand a bit in terms
of the difference between T 1 and T 2
and the difference between t2 and t3 you
can quickly check that these two are the
same the top has half of t1 and in the
bottom there are two minus signs in
front of the t1 so it's positive and the
half has been factored out likewise both
have half of t3 then on the bottom we
have a negative t2 that's effectively
written twice so when you take half of
that it's the same as the single
negative t2 written up top like I said
the reason to rewrite it is that it
takes us a step closer to the language
of derivatives in fact let's go ahead
and write these guys as delta T 1 and
delta T 2 it's the same value on the
right hand side but we're adding a new
perspective to how to think about it
instead of comparing the average of the
neighbors to T 2 we're thinking about
the difference of the differences here
take a moment to get check that this
makes sense if those two differences are
the same then the average of T 1 and T 3
is the same as T 2 so T 2 will not tend
to change if delta T 2 is bigger than
delta T 1 meaning the difference of the
differences is positive notice how the
average of T 1 and T 3 is
than t2 so t2 tends to increase and on
the flip side if the difference of the
differences is negative which means
delta T 2 is smaller than delta T 1 it
corresponds to an average of these
neighbors being less than t2 we could be
especially compact with our notation and
write this whole term the difference
between the differences as delta delta T
1 this is known in the lingo as a second
difference if it feels a little weird to
think about keep in mind it's
essentially a compact way of writing the
idea of how much t2 differs from the
average of its neighbors it just has
this extra factor of 1/2 is all and that
factor doesn't really matter because
either way we're writing this equation
in terms of some proportionality
constant the upshot is that the rate of
change for the temperature of a point is
proportional to the second difference
around it as we go from this finite
context to the infinite continuous case
the analog of a second difference is the
second derivative instead of looking at
the difference between the temperature
values at points some fixed distance
apart you instead consider what happens
as you shrink this size of that step
toward zero and in calculus instead of
talking about absolute differences which
would also approach zero you think in
terms of the rate of change in this case
what's the rate of change in temperature
per unit distance and remember there are
two separate rates of change at play how
does that temperature change as time
progresses and how does the temperature
change as you move along the rod the
core intuition remains the same is what
we had in the discrete case to know how
a point differs from its neighbors look
not just at how the function changes
from one point to the next but at how
the rate of change itself changes
now in calculus land we write this as
del squared T over del x squared the
second partial derivative of our
function with respect to X notice how
the slope increases at points where the
graph curves upwards meaning the rate of
change of the rate of change is positive
similarly that slope decreases at points
where the graph curves downwards where
the rate of change of this rate of
change is negative took that away as a
meaningful intuition for problems well
beyond the heat equation second
derivatives give a measure of how we
value compares to the average of its
neighbors hopefully that gives some
satisfying added color to the equation
it's already pretty intuitive when you
read it as saying that curved points
tend to flatten out but I think there's
something even more satisfying about
seeing a partial differential equation
like this arise almost mechanistically
from thinking about each point as simply
tending towards the average of its
neighbors take a moment to compare what
this feels like to the case of ordinary
differential equations for example if we
have multiple bodies in space tugging at
each other with gravity what we're
analyzing is a handful of changing
numbers in this case the coordinates of
each object the rate of change for any
one of these values depends on the
values of the other numbers and we often
write this down as a system of equations
on the Left we have the derivative of
each value with respect to time and on
the right there's some combination of
all the other values in our partial
differential equation the difference is
that we have infinitely many values
changing from a continuum and again the
way that any one of these values changes
depends on the other values but quite
helpfully each one only depends on its
immediate neighbors in some limiting
sense of the word neighbor so here the
relation on the right-hand side is not a
sum or product of the other numbers it's
instead a kind of derivative just a
derivative with respect to space instead
of with respect to time in a sense when
you think about it this one partial
differential equation is like a system
of infinitely many equations one for
each point on the rod
[Music]
you might wonder about objects which are
spread out in more than one dimension
like a plate or something
three-dimensional in that case the
equation looks quite similar but you
include the second derivative with
respect to the other spatial directions
as well and adding up all of these
second spatial derivatives like this is
common enough as an operation that it
has its own special name the laplacian
often written as this upside-down
triangle squared it's essentially a
multivariable version of the second
derivative and the intuition for this
equation is no different from the
one-dimensional case this laplacian can
still be thought of as measuring how
different is a point from the average of
its neighbors but now these neighbors
aren't just left and right of it they
are all around for the curious among you
I did a couple of videos during my time
at Khan Academy on this operator if you
want to go check them out for those of
you with some multi variable calculus
under your belt it's nice to think about
as the divergence of the gradient but
you don't have to worry about that for
our purposes let's stay focused on the
one-dimensional case if you feel like
you understand all of this pat yourself
on the back being able to read a PDE is
no joke and it's a powerful addition to
have to your vocabulary for describing
the world around you but after all of
this time spent interpreting the
equations I say it's high time that we
start solving them don't you and trust
me there are a few pieces of math quite
as satisfying as what poodle haired
Fourier overhere developed to solve this
problem all this and more in the next
chapter
I was originally motivated to cover this
particular topic when I got an early
view of Steve Strogatz his new book
infinite powers this isn't a sponsored
message or anything like that but all
cards on the table I do have two selfish
ulterior motives for mentioning it the
first is that Steve has been a really
strong maybe even pivotal advocate for
the channel since the very beginnings
and I've had an itch to repay that
kindness for quite a while and the
second is to make more people love math
and calculus in particular that might
not sound selfish but think about it
when more people love math the potential
audience base for these videos gets
bigger and frankly there are a few
better ways to get people loving the
subject than to expose them to Strogatz
as writing so if you have friends who
you know who you think would enjoy the
ideas of calculus but maybe have been a
bit intimidated by math in the past this
book does a really outstanding job
communicating the heart of the subject
both substantively and excessively its
main theme is the idea of constructing
solutions to complex real world problems
from simple idealized building blocks
which as you'll see is exactly what
Fourier did and for those of you who
already know and love the subject you
will find no shortage of fresh insights
and enlightening stories I certainly
enjoyed it again I kind of know that
sounds like an ad but it's not I just
actually think you'll enjoy the book
[Music]
you
[Music]
you